okay this is a how to play diamond
digger saga
walkthrough tutorial
from uh
diamond digger saga tips
or a website that writes tips and
helps you figure out how to play the
game
this is from our basics
section that we're working on now but we
also write level guides and
help you figure out how to get through
the toughest levels
we also make videos um
i'll show you how it's done so
this is our hero diggy
he's um
he's a little character i'm not sure
what to call him but
he likes to dig and um
we have we see there's uh you know the
number of moves on the side how many
points we have to get this is the points
level
and um
click on that and
look at the board
all right so it's telling us that we
have to click on groups of time and play
the box to score points
um pretty simple
one thing about diamond digger that's
different than other games you might be
used to
is it's not a swiping game you don't
swipe
diamonds um
left to right
or right to left or up or down or
whatever what you do is you click on
groups of light colored diamonds
and
that will remove them from the board so
you can see i'm hovering over the pink
diamonds right now that's gonna if i
click on that it's gonna move
all nine of those diamonds and take out
the ground blocks that are blown
and
one interesting thing to think about is
these diamonds are above water
if i click on those
you'll see that i don't get any points
okay
so when you're trying to collect points
and especially in this case we're only
have to get a very low amount of points
you're going to want to be able to make
matches over water or that aren't over
water so that you can pick up some
points and this is a really simple level
obviously but i figured we'd start at
the beginning so
you can see there i got about 90 points
on those
um we'll go ahead and work our way down
now we're up to 150
up to 10 so
just need a couple more matches and
we'll have our points
you can see this is six blocks
six diamonds over six ground blocks and
we need 50 points so that's going to
give us 60
and then this up to 310
so that's the absolute simplest um
level
um but the main things to keep in mind
here are that it's a
it's what's called a collapsing style
match three so you need three diamonds
of the same color or more in a group
and when you match them together
you uh they'll remove and they'll fall
down
and the board sort of collapses
and
one thing to keep in mind is there's no
cascades in this type of game so
making matches at the bottom of the
board doesn't cause any other matches to
happen above it can just set them up
all right so we're going to look at the
map and talk about some things here um
the ones that have this icon that just
the diamonds in in a bubble
those are
just points levels okay
and you can see up here we get into the
other types this is a fireflies level
so
and all these you see points and then
the little rubber ducky is a toys level
so those have different requirements
it's not just not about collecting
points
and when we get way up the map
to level 71 plus you'll see this icon
that's a totem's level
so we'll make individual videos about
each of those
and how those level requirements work
but for now let's go to a different
level and
i'll just stick with points for now and
talk about how this game works
one thing that's cool about diamond
digger is that they're always adding new
um
new features and things in the game
um
so as you get to the higher levels
there's plenty of different things to
figure out
um here we have to collect 12 000 points
we can see there's a big lock on the on
the door this is at the exit
and i guess i should just explain that
in the first place first level we played
was just one room
most of the levels in diamond digger
have multiple rooms and what you have to
do is you have to leave water which
starts at an entrance
out through the exit okay
so here
this ice
the ice can be
removed by making matches next to it as
you can see like that
but
it only you know only the match only the
ice blocks that are
directly touching the match will be
removed so you have to you have to bust
away at it and when you see a lock at
the bottom
you have to let you have to
lead the water to the actual key
in order to
open the lock and then you can bring the
water down itself so
these ground blocks here are
a little bit tougher to remove the brown
ones are just one match and they'll be
gone the ones with the cracked
stone on them take two
and the ones with solid stone take three
so you'll see when i make this match
here i'll turn these ones into
a ground brown brown box and these two
on the outside that are brown already
will just disappear
so it's pretty straightforward
so we're going to remove a little bit
more ice so that we can get the water
out of there
and then you can see we can make a pink
one here
i'm just going to go ahead and get rid
of the water to get the water out first
and now the key is
has been freed and the lock has been
removed
so now we just need to work our way down
and we'll just do that planning out how
they're going to fall as you can see
like i was saying the cascade there is
no cascade
so planning is pretty important here and
another thing is when you have points
you'll see the striped
blocks and then there's some different
kinds those contain a treasure
underneath
and
as you go deeper the treasure goes up in
value so one of the things you want to
do is you want to keep in mind how much
you get whenever you match these so if
you get stuck you can
decide whether they're worth going after
later or not when you play it when you
replay the level
so this is only worth 100 points so
that's not very valuable there's some
that are up to like 1200 points or 2 000
points i should say
so that's just something to keep in mind
we don't want to spend a lot of moves
going after treasures that are only
worth 100 points
so we're going to make this match here
that's going to clear out this ice and
that's going to get us out the door
another thing to know is that each level
in
diamond digger saga has a rechargeable
booster
so watch as we're making matches you'll
see how this thing charges up and
um this is this is essential in a lot of
levels um we make all our videos
no boosters but we use the ones in game
that recharge because they're designed
with it and um
they're pretty much necessary to get
through a lot of these levels
so you can see as i made that match
it filled up a little bit more big
matches fill this up faster
than small matches do so you always want
to look for big matches when you're
trying to charge it
and
this next room is the exact same concept
we only got 500 points there so
what we're doing is we're probably
trying to move through these as fast as
we can to get to the treasure room which
i'll explain when we get there
so for now um
we'll just go ahead and try to get out
of this room as fast as we can we need
to
get the water to the locks
to the keys so we can undo the lock
so i just made a little match at the top
to get the water started
make a big batch at the bottom to
drop the ice down a little bit
and we're just gonna step by step move
the uh water that way
we'll get to the first key there and our
boot our booster is really close to
being charged now so we'll be able to
use that to help us out
so we click on this
and you can see that it not only
explodes the ones that are free from
nice but it also explodes or clears the
ones that are trapped in ice
so by using this blue on blue you can
use it on any color on the board
but by using it on blue here we'll get
this match together so that we can
leave the water to the second key
and we already have water down to the
lock so that'll also get us out of the
room
so you when you want to use this you can
just click on any of one of the color
that you want and it removes them
and now all we need to do is match these
green diamonds and we get out of the
room
so we got a little bit more points there
we got 3600 but um
you know it we have 16 moves left so
everything's fine even though it looks
like we have a little amount of points
compared to what the goal is we just
want to keep moving
so i made that match over the
the heavy one the heavy stone blocks so
that i could
start to get them removed
and also clear out a bunch of ice in the
process
so we're just going to keep moving a lot
of times in this game it's good to you
know go from the top down because you
don't
um
change up any of the ones that are below
and like i said since there's no cascade
or no action above like
it's it's not as valuable make matches
at the bottom as it is in other games
that you're probably familiar with
however when you don't have the matches
you need up top then you have to make
them below
so that um
you know it'll switch things up all
right so here we can match the red but
that's not going to get the water to the
exit so we look around and the blue will
actually get it right on this one match
so we'll make that one instead
and that gave us enough points because
those treasures you just saw were worth
a thousand
um
so this is this is gone for about 11
minutes so i'm going to go ahead and
stop there
you can see you know you get stars just
like the other games you get um
there's a high score board
these levels change sometimes so some of
these higher scores are
possibly from when the level is
different us when you see a score like
this this person didn't play fair um
it's not possible to get 10 times what
the regular people are getting so
if you see these all the time you can
just unfriend that person because
they're not playing
normally
they're using cheats
let's just go back out into the world
again
another quick couple things it has when
you get to the end of level 40 for the
first time it's going to have
locks on these right here
the way you get past those is by asking
your friends for help with the ticket
which is normal
for the other games as well
you don't need it till you get to level
40 but every other episode unless you're
already at the end you need to unlock as
you go
we have our
you turn the sound or music on or off
you can put it in full screen
if you're in a level there's an extra
icon here to quit the level so like if
you know you're not going to finish and
you're just frustrated you can go ahead
and quit
by clicking on that
it doesn't show it out in the world
because we're not playing a level
you have a messages box just like you do
in the other it has a limit of 50
but if you have more
friends
requests waiting after you get done with
these if you
click on one of these requests like this
it'll refill the box um i'll show you
that real quick
but just to give you a thing here you
have lives that come in
you have requests for lives
and then you also get the valuable plus
two boosters which um
we don't use for our videos but they can
come in handy on a lot of heavy uh
a lot of difficult boards so i'm gonna
do real quick is just show you i'm gonna
accept all which is always a good habit
to get into before you leave the game
because that means that you're returning
your request and you'll get more in to
have more labs later
and
i'm just waiting a second until it's
done clearing
all right so um
this is going to be off the screen a
little bit what i'm doing though is i'm
going to where my my
alerts are for notifications
and
i look for the ones for diamond digger
and
i click on them
and then you'll see that the the
the messages are refilled so now i have
48 more again and this is an unlock
request that's what i was talking about
where you have to ask your friend so i'm
going to fill this
and since i'm finishing the video and
leaving the game i'm going to accept all
again
so we have more videos like this coming
out to explain all the different parts
of the game
if you have any questions on how to play
you can leave a comment on this video
you can visit our website
diamondbiggersagatips.com
or you can join our facebook group
where we have lots of lots of players
at the time making this video we have
over three thousand so
you can always find friends and ask tips
for the game there it's the fastest way
to get in touch with us
so we recommend you do that if like i
said if you find this video helpful go
ahead and like it and just let us know
if you have any questions thanks